if you think about bodybuilding and
translating the bodybuilding world to
Business Development when I was
competing you do a 12-week cut two weeks
out I was doing an hour on the
StairMaster three four times a week as
well as doing weight training like seven
eight times a week when you're on the
StairMaster the first families you're
thinking I've got this and then the next
families you're thinking why have I
started then the next temperature I I
can't do this I don't think I can do
this then you get to 40 minutes you're
like I've got this and that first part
of the journey is always the hardest bit
with business development and it's just
like being on the StairMaster or
whatever your interest is whatever's hot
translate that to visit development
welcome back to another episode of the
recruitment mentors podcast I'm your
host hiisha mizzouz and on this week's
episode I was joined by Ash Goodwin
after working the police for six years
you had a career change and he found
himself working in the recruitment
industry after nearly three years
working for a company climbing the ranks
and becoming one of their top performers
he then started his entrepreneurial
Journey just before covid and launched
his recruitment business called ardor
Talon he then more recently went on to
start another recruitment business
called my product path which is a SAS
service a self-serve play as well as a
recruitment company I'll be honest I
challenged ash a lot in this episode in
terms of the way that they're thinking
about the future recruitment how he
thinks it will be I definitely pushed on
a number of things that he thought in a
healthy way but we also broke down his
approach to winning business standing
out mindset and so much more enjoy the
episode Ash welcome to the podcast thank
you great to be here oh yeah thanks for
um coming into the studio I appreciate
it obviously we we've sort of just
crossed paths or spoken a couple of
times on LinkedIn didn't we
um and I know you're extremely
passionate about changing the perception
of the industry correct yeah a bit like
I am and also I think what what prompted
US during this was sort of the way that
you're building your more recent
business is really centered around
changing the perception industry doing
things differently
I think you said that there's a lot of
people on LinkedIn talking about doing
things differently but are they actually
doing it one million percent you believe
that yeah the way that you're trying to
build things you are actually doing it
so I'm excited to dive into how Ash is
approaching on actually actioning that
but I guess just to like always sort of
like to start with just a pen a bit of
color on as your journey so far so if
I'm missing anything let me know
so
you worked in the police for over six
years yep correct definitely gonna talk
about that from police to recruitment
you then sort of worked in recruitment
employed for a business businesses for
yeah nearly three years
where you had sort of early success was
a minor Contract Services right yeah
correct so you worked there for two and
a half years and became one of their
High performers there and then August
2019 or in 2019 he then started outdoor
Talent yeah and recruitment business
couple of months seven months half a
year before covid
yeah that was fun yeah yeah so so you
started starting your own business then
you've been on an entrepreneurial
Journey since then right so yeah you've
been on the entrepreneurial Journey
since 2019
um yeah initially started that with idle
talent but then nearly 18 months ago you
started a other recruitment business
called my product path
um with your co-founder Sean who's a
product expert worked in the in the
product world for however many years and
now it's more of like a group older
Talent there's more Finance
property or not yeah so property
technology Finance compliance
um although we'll be winding down and be
spitting out more arms of my product
path so my finance path my compliance
path Etc yeah cool so yeah so then and
then yeah my product path I feel like
from I don't know you tell me but I feel
like that's where you see the long term
what the main focus is going to be like
you just said yeah one minute one
million percent it's almost like our
Innovation Hub and then it's become the
Forefront of the business cool and then
so like you uh Connie shared with me so
in your last Financial year
you put it you pull it as a group right
in terms of this yeah there's 14 of you
and then basically yeah combine group 10
I've been the last Financial year 1.4
million and 780 Grand is in GP and for
my product path specifically just under
300 Grand in um gross profit
so I feel like yeah you've been on an
interesting Journey right like things
have evolved met your co-founder started
that so yeah I'm really excited to get
into this and I think the world the way
that we'll break this down is let's
definitely talk about Ash the recruiter
get into the detail of that and then
we'll we'll dive into the
entrepreneurial Journey things that
you've had to learn um and we'll focus
on that but I guess where we always like
to start million pound question
something you've probably thought about
since having your own business yeah what
Sasha's take on what are the the
characteristics and traits that make up
a highly successful recruit in today's
market let's start there yeah I always
love this question and I'm going to
answer it non-traditionally so I've
obviously listened to your podcast
historically and everyone says work
ethic Etc so
one question I always ask an interview
is what is the greatest challenge you've
overcome
and the reason why I set questions
because I'm looking for resilience is a
key factor of a successful recruiter
and once somebody understands the
process of overcoming a challenge
they can translate that into recruitment
because in recruitment every single day
we have challenges every single day
throwing out as left right and Center so
resilience for me is a massive massive
factor and that's coupled with
discipline
motivation will get you to start
something and discipline will get you to
finish it the person who's disciplined
will always outwork and outbeat somebody
who's just got a bit of motivation here
and there and I think that's the
difference between a hard worker and
somebody who works hard
there's two differences there someone
can work hard for a period of time but
the hard work who's disciplined can do
the micro tasks
and get to the macro level by doing that
and I think the third point I would go
through here is a problem identifier and
a problem solver
the job of a salesperson is to find pain
points and needs and provide solutions
for that
so someone who's really really good
at uncovering that
is incredibly successful in recruitment
because fundamentally that's the job of
a salesperson so I think they're they're
the free which I would identify as I
guess the key characteristics and just
to add another one in there is the
executor
I've had people in my business over the
last couple of years
who've had fantastic ideas
but can't execute
so having fantastic ideas you need that
in your company you need somebody to
challenge you for from a continuous
Improvement perspective
however when you compare them against
the executor the executor will provide
better service and out Bill the person
with the good ideas because a person
with good ideas thinks that that's the
only way to do it because it's their way
so I would take someone with 99
execution and wants and ideas over 99
ideas and one percent execution every
single day of the week so there's so
many more to it but they're the four
things I I probably look for closely
when I'm interviewing recruiters because
I know that I can use that and make them
successful and bring the best out of
them
so let me let me ask you then yes what
what's been the biggest challenge that
you've had to overcome
what from recruitment or in business
if if he was to be asked that question
how would you answer it
from a personal aspect it was when I
left the police to transition into a new
career um
I went through a real real dark period
and you get an exclusive here because
I've not spoken about this in public
exclusive and I I went through a super
super dark period
um from a mental aspect I I was
completely completely lost so the
biggest challenge I've overcome is
learning how to walk away from a job
which is fundamentally a career
move into something which is the fitness
industry where everyone says you should
follow your passion
I did that I began to hate it I resented
the thing that I was I loved the most I
really hated it
um I had no money
I was in a complete dark period
completely lost so the biggest challenge
I overcome was overcoming the mental
aspects of Ash and then relearning who I
was having to relearn empathy because
when you're in a place you have no well
you have empathy for people but you have
like bad stuff happens all the time one
of my friends came to me and said my
granddad passed away and I went okay
well unfortunately people died like
that's just part of life I'm not a
friend there I'm a robot so relearning
the empathy side of things of life was
was really interesting so from my
perspective it's overcoming the mental
challenges of myself that's the hardest
thing I've ever done when you can't
leave a side of it
you're fearless and you're so powerful
you're literally like Superman the woman
because
no one's putting the phone down on you
can never hurt you it doesn't matter
does it you've you've beaten yourself up
enough mentally the rest of it's fine
no thank you for sharing that I think I
think a lot of people
can find themselves in those moments
so let if if you don't mind let's just
talk about that for a sec because I
think this would be helpful for people
so being being lost like what did that
actually look like so are you talking
about yeah he was in in the police which
I'm assuming people around you
or sort of the people that you could
look up to had been doing it for over a
decade or it was like their entire life
and you you obviously left that after
six years
so was it what the hell do I do now and
sort of dealing with those types of
questions
so when I was in the police I I was one
of the first people not the first people
but I started I've always had businesses
on the side so when was Nepali say I got
paid extra to do like modeling and
Hollister stuff and all that great stuff
and then I started selling Fitness plans
and then I sold makeup and I was selling
makeup I was selling anything that I
could do and I was making more money
from doing that than what I was in the
police and I knew it was the right time
to leave the police because I wanted to
live a life where I could be home to see
my children
my wife wouldn't be worrying whenever
you go out and unfortunately unfortunate
event happened in the place where two of
my colleagues were unfortunately
murdered and that was a moment when I
was like I'm 23 years of age at the time
I'm not doing this forever wow so I'm
I'm getting out I'm going
and it was kind of like when you leave
and then you pursue your passion I
pursued Fitness it was my passion I
competed I was on to a good thing and
when you start to hate your passion
it contradicts that everything everyone
says where you should follow your
passion
and it was more the aspect of thinking I
had it figured out by following the
fitness sector
and realizing that I just wasn't right
that's my personal passion not my career
passion which are two different things
and then you should beat yourself up you
feel like you've failed and I failed at
like probably three or four different
businesses
trying to create businesses during that
period and then they did the fitness
sector which it was a shoe in it was a
dead sir I I had to be successful at it
it didn't work it was working but I was
miserable so it was more I I thought I
was at the thought I was at the end of
my journey with failure when there's
actually at the start of the journey and
I had to just relearn myself it was like
an evolution period everyone goes
through it you have to learn about who
you are and what you are and then you
become a mentality content with yourself
and then you can move forward
but as you go through that journey in
that period where you're lost and you
don't know who you are you don't know
what your values are anymore you just
completely like you just can't see
through to what like the end of the road
that was probably the most challenging
aspect to come through and I think every
person in the world goes through this
yeah definitely like like that's a dead
set
I think the thing to get through is just
realizing that when you're in a tough
period just don't stop keep going take a
moment to reflect look at your good
points and bad points but keep moving
forwards so for me it was Lou I felt
like I'd lost it all I had no idea what
I wanted to do next
like no idea
it's a scary place to be isn't it yeah
and I had no degree as well said no
degree no nothing to fall back on
I was all in and it just didn't work out
which was a blessing in disguise
and we found a world of recruitment
I did I did what I did what everyone did
I got to Google I was like what am I
good at
I'm good with people
I'm good at solving problems
that's a good starting point I Googled
it and I also wanted to make money which
is why everyone gets into Recruitment
and the recruitment was the first one
which came up and goes well I don't see
why I can't do that and I just applied
so
let's just talk about
like looking back at
um
Ash being employed because I feel like
that that sort of Journey says a lot as
to like why we've ended up sort of where
you've ended up so far I feel like like
clearly you had that sort of
entrepreneurial energy and spirit quite
early on
you were sort of thinking how can I
support myself how can I be reliant on
myself yeah and it seems like even when
he was in in the police
so I think that goes back to be the kid
like I think it all starts there it's
the old cliche selling stuff and selling
cigarettes sweets washing cars getting
your mate to wash your cars have been
taking half the money like the whole
journey there it started there but
entrepreneurism when I was what 22 years
ago 20 years ago
we didn't have social media so you
didn't really know if it's inherent in
you you don't actually you didn't know
it back then so that's why I went to the
police to learn discipline
um and then obviously
our social media become more Paramount
and I started to learn more about myself
I was like I actually need to be doing
this
so with what what did you what like
looking back what did you
um where did you where did you struggle
the most when you was employed in like
so you obviously you worked uh how do
you pronounce it
yeah what were some of your biggest
challenges early on in that business
because was it is it contract or was it
perm uh both so yeah they men are a
great company they do lots in
engineering and
and defense and my job was to come in
and actually help shape and grow a
technology desk
um
the CEO Gary He's a fantastic guy he's a
he's a really good leader
um I think
I I'm a hard person to manage
um I'm so self-sufficient you can leave
me alone I'll go and do it I'll know
I'll grow something and I'll do
something fantastic I'm Easy in terms of
to manage from that aspect but I'm hard
in terms of like I will always push
continuous Improvement
I will because I I want to work for the
best company possible and I think the
the big I guess challenge there was
understanding I had it took me a couple
of years to figure this out that my
vision and their Vision was different
and that's okay
it just meant that my vision didn't
align with their Vision anymore
so it's more the vision aspect which is
the reason why I kind of left it's
because I kind of saw recruitment going
a different avenue to what to what they
did and that was okay because their
business wasn't fit for my purpose
longer term it was fit for their purpose
and because obviously I write down
memory prepared for this
that you became
one of the top formers quite quickly
yeah correct
a big part of that from what you shared
with me was around how you got good at
winning new business building
partnership something that
um you said you you feel you're great at
yes like what why were you able to get
some sort of early success on on the
business development side do you think
why was you able to do that a lot of
people struggled with that yeah it's a
good question I mean when I left the
turnover the business unit was 2.6
million and that's in the two and a half
year period so it was it was quick
success what what I realized I was very
good at I'm I'm
it's the ability to be ruthlessly
tenacious so if you think about
bodybuilding and translating the
bodybuilding world to Business
Development when I was competing you do
a 12-week cut
and four I think it's like for two weeks
out I was doing a thousands calories in
the StairMaster an hour on the
StairMaster three four times a week as
well as well as doing weight training
like seven eight times a week it was and
then you're on like 14 1500 calories it
was ruthless when you go through the
period And this is interesting because I
use this as an analogy to my Consultants
it's translating a process which works
into business development
when you're on the StairMaster the first
five minutes you thinking I've got this
well most people are thinking I've got
this and then the next families you're
thinking why have I started then the
next temperature I I can't do this I
don't think I can do this then you get
halfway thinking I just want to start
but can I get going then you get to 40
minutes you're like I've got this and
that first part of the journey is always
the hardest bit with business
development
and it's just like being on the
StairMaster or whatever your interest is
whatever's hot translate that to
Business Development and with business
development it's initially a numbers
game my mission was to bring on as many
clients as I could
in in the fastest period possible
I brought on a travel company which
almost changed my life
as a travel company as a financial
services company there's two different
stories but the travel company
right from them right time and my
ability to build relationships off the
back of just I guess being myself that's
how I won the business and then it was
not only that it was taken out to dinner
Landing them expanding them getting
introduced to the next person then the
next person and then the next person but
fundamentally you're the problem solver
they know they come to me I'm gonna I
will work through the night I'll work
over the weekends I will get the job
done so they can grow their business and
they can grow their teams so it's a
mixture of being reliable
tenacious consistent and
understanding what they want so
understanding what the Horizon actually
wants versus what you think that they
want
so from a business development
standpoint
the three biggest Partners I brought on
were all the first year and that wasn't
by luck that was from work ethic
I five o'clock till seven o'clock in the
evening I I kind of worked those two
hours wherever on the gun home at half
five
sending out sales emails specking
candidates over who are reliable to
sorry relevant to write parties I did
that day in day out week in week out for
an 18-month period
and that's kind of what helped to grow
the business I outworked everybody else
in the office
so what if if it's cool with you we've
spoken a lot about this recently on the
podcast and I think people have really
appreciated it so you can you can maybe
take
take experiences of now with my product
path or more with your own business but
I guess
I really like the way that you broke
down that stair Master experience like I
think a lot of people relate to that
like you said I think it is is so true
those first five minutes
you've got it then after that you're
like why the have I done this like
like I couldn't relate more so that
makes complete sense so
I guess like taking that then into the
business development context I think
that that makes complete sense so I
guess what what does Ash's like Business
Development strategy now look like you
know what I mean so if and we can break
that down where you're you're making
sure you do the things even though you
may not want to be doing them or just
how that translates it'd be good to just
get your perspective on that or how you
now approach things because I think this
will be really helpful for people so
let's just say
I don't know now with my product path
you've got 10 dream clients you know who
they are you feel like you can solve
their problems add tremendous amounts of
value to them
um what is Ash's strategy um that like
you said sometimes you may not want to
do it but you know you need to do it to
take those people from not knowing who
you are to having that first meeting
um with you where you get the
opportunity to sort of showcase this is
what I'm about this is why I'm someone
that's reliable like just talk to us and
feel free to go as Grand as you want but
what does that look like yeah I've been
there two parts to the question because
you've got Ash is a recruitment
consultant in Maine and you've got Ash
now where I've already got a client base
I can pick and choose almost who I want
to work with what I've always done is
in order for me to sell a company and
sell a position I've got to be
passionate about the person and the
company so first and foremost I'm
looking at okay
which companies are doing things in my
opinion ethically in the correct way
I don't want to be partnering with
companies where you hear horror stories
about people leaving after four or five
months continuously not just anomalies
continuously so my business development
plans now more okay who can I add value
to and who can add value to me it's a
two-way street because the development
is and when you start out you always
think it's a one-way street because you
put the senior people on the pedestal
you do
back here it was the micro steps it was
hitting the kpis hitting the numbers it
is a numbers game it's getting people to
it's been planned so planning is super
critical to being successful Improvement
four to five every day I'll be planning
five to seven I'll be the normal sales
emails spec and CVS 9 to 11 every single
day I be calling I'll be I'll be had a
targeted list in specific Industries
that you call now when people get into
recruitment they say I will work in the
sports industry because Gaming's really
cool or whatever it is just just kind of
that's kind of what they say I ended up
in travel
and then look at data and then then SAS
like their Industries I didn't even
think about but it's where I got the
results and then you build an almost a
business off the back of it if I'm
working with what foxy listed business
you're one of the biggest companies in
the world which we've worked with for
the last seven years
I'm gonna use them to Market out to
other companies because it's a clever
way to do business and people want to
work with the best
they they do and if they know you're
delivering talent to those to those
companies so I I think when you're
starting out you almost go for
everything and then it's like a big
stagger sales funnel you start with
everything and then you get to this
stage here like okay I'm at this stage
here now where I'm like okay who do I
want to work with
why do they why should I reach out to
them
because people reach out to me now
so it's almost my BD plans now a two-way
street versus how is my product path
going to benefit this company in the
future because we're not right to work
with everybody
at the start your journey you want to
work with everybody everybody and that's
like that's part that's part of business
so my business plan now is more
structured around how we can add value I
still cold call
I actually personally love it I really
like it and sat there with the lads in
the office and the girls in the office
cold calling
so it's more having a structured plan
but having a plan which is long term I'm
talking five years down the line which
of these customers do we want to be
working with
what products they're building which are
really cool how can we Supply the people
to build those products out
because I'm going to probably use that
product and yeah it'd be so you feel
quite proud of the fact you supplied the
right people so my business plan now is
more around that but back when I first
started it was more around volume
numbers
basically where can you get the the wins
quicker
at month 10 I'll learn how to win
exclusivity and that's what changed my
career in recruitment you learn how to
win an exclusivity yeah I've won my
third I want the director of it
exclusive role with
um a company in Leicester
so comical Cambridge account is Bank
fantastic business I've worked them for
a long time and I will exclusivity on
that work on that one role and I came
out and I realized what my worth was
and then when you do that in recruitment
you don't settle for competing X5
companies anymore you've done it once
you can do the process over and over and
over and over
well let's talk about that then I think
that'd be helpful yeah
what so
how let me ask you this maybe this will
bring it out
but what was Ash doing in a so I'm
assuming Did you sort of ask for
exclusivity in the clock meeting yeah
Okay cool so what did a client meeting
look like when you didn't get
exclusivity so maybe
six months in
what questions are you asking what were
you focusing on to then what did that
meeting look like and how different was
it when you did get exclusivity when it
was like 10 months in as you said what
were like the main differences like yeah
be interested because I think that'll
bring to life the different types of
questions you're asking what you're
focusing on rather than what you ended
up focusing on when you walked away
understanding your worth with
exclusivity and like you said that that
sort of changed your career so yeah how
different were the meetings yeah a lot
of it was confident so
when I was at my first recruitment
company they they labored the point of
booking meetings and going out of
meetings and get in front of people and
when you do when you first start the
meetings are generally I would say
rubbish but
you're learning and you're gaining
experience and there's no structure and
you my meetings were all around the
people getting the people to talk not
talking about Recruitment and then
getting people to like me I like them
and that's how you win business and
that's kind of like the first six months
was just around
I was almost you can you can smell the
not smell the desperation you can almost
smell the desperation of this recruiter
really needs this um
where is it month 10 I'd actually
already worked with one of the HR
managers in the previous company I'd I
did five deals with her
um during that period but she also had a
a boss who I had to get on side so I
kind of had I had half a hunch I could
do it and I think that ability to
understand that you can do it like you
you're probably very selfish and we've
done meetings before
I get myself so psyched up now for
meetings I've already won the business
before I even go in
and that's what I did on that day
whereas these meetings here it's almost
like you're you're faking it a little
bit you know you're you know you know
you're not bad at recruitment but are
you confident you're better than anyone
else out there probably not at that
stage
so those meetings here were just a bit
more looking back not great
understandably
and that and does nothing there's no
targeted outcomes that I wanted from
those meetings just go to meetings
hopefully when business come back to the
office this meeting here was
specifically for one job
I had to go and pitch for it so I got
the data
got all the LinkedIn data had case
studies
I was probably the most prepared I've
ever been for a meeting in my life and
then in that meeting I asked them Point
Blank
I only work exclusively how would you
feel about working the exclusive on this
role
I didn't really work exclusively at the
time but I said it because I'm like I
need to I need to I need to win this
exclusively I'm not going to do this
role when I'm competing I don't want to
do that life anymore and they they were
brought in and they said might need some
time to think about guys well let me
just kind of stop you there like when
people say because they're not convinced
it talk me through the reason why you
need more time then I was able to answer
the question and then we won the
business I closed there so it was that
almost that switch where before I
probably would have gone like here I'd
have gone all right okay yeah I look
forward to hearing from you
whereas In This Moment was like no I'm
winning this
I'm not going to leave this office until
I won this business and that was the
difference in the two me and the
meetings here versus the meeting here
there's a targeted outcome there's no
targeted outcomes here
what was that question you just said
because that's that's that's very
helpful for people well that exclusivity
so basically so like you just said it
was they said Ash I think I might just
have to think about it and you replied
with
typically when people say that they're
still unsure what is it that you're
unsure about yeah correct because it's
true and and I think you and I both been
in meetings before where they say that
and people say this often and it's
always the case that they're not
entirely convinced by you yet or you
haven't sold your solution well enough
so when anyone says that to me I always
Circle back I'm like okay fantastic I
can obviously appreciate that my
experience suggests that
when people say this is because not
entirely convinced to what part of the
process you're not convinced about
and then you get an opportunity then
overcome your objection again and sell
the solutions so it was that bit there
which I'll be honest I learned that from
a YouTube video on on sales I thought
I'm just going to try it and it worked I
think it's one of those things where I
was like okay now I'm going to do it
again then I can now put into my
language seven years later as to how I
would do it now but back then it was
like I was almost obsessed with sales to
a point where
I I outside of work I was always self
developed developing and improving and
trying stuff and eventually when you're
trying to stuff some stuff works through
some doesn't and that was just one of
the things which worked in that period
yeah and then just just to wrap that up
I know everyone granted granular here
but I know people really enjoy their
stuff
um so people listening
What would
like now know what you know I'm sure you
have your guys and girls with it now
new client meeting I'm excited about the
like they fit sort of I think they're um
a great business they've got low
turnover
um fits are sort of Ideal sort of um
type of client and I think it could be a
really great partnership what would be
the non-negotiable things that you plan
for in that meeting now I don't know
what would like for people listening
what should they plan for
non-negotiable as a minimum rather than
going into these types of meetings just
hoping it goes well trying a bit of
relationship and hopefully I'll win some
business like what would be the
non-negotiable prep for these uh
potential
um new client meetings yeah it's a great
question and I think it starts with how
like you mentioned there like
how you qualify the prospect so from the
qualification phase that's how you do
your prep so let's just say
company building out a product function
they're going to need 20 hires
which is what happened back in August it
said running through the data and
analytics on the company
um so understanding where they've
acquired Talent from before
because usually LinkedIn analytics is
great nowadays everyone everyone uses it
it's really clever so I'm always looking
at that but then let's just say in this
instance where they're having to grow
different squads
it's having I I honestly just sit down
with Sean say Sean okay this is this is
what we have this is what they want to
build
I need an idea when they're going to the
meeting they might need two product
managers here and a product owner here
and maybe a designer here and an
engineer here I need to understand this
formation of what the squad what a good
squad looks like what a good formation
of a business looks like so I think
force and film is having that
high level knowledge is super critical
and then also
I think in that meeting I said about
product operations which is quite a new
thing in products it's it's been around
but it's super new so it's asserting
yourself as that expert as well because
the CP goes you know I thought about it
but not not too much sometimes I need to
come back to you one
and you instantly assert yourself as the
almost the the expert the dominant in
that meeting
so I think I think that's the first and
foremost then it's okay
exclusivity is key we only work with
that
um in terms of business and then I I
from I guess from a research perspective
it's more just the analytics and just
looking at the squad formation
um looking at the person I'm working
with looking at the company we're
working with what's attractive about
them to sell
um getting them to tell me why somebody
should work there so the meetings for me
now are more on the client than me
delivering on the meetings because
people already know what I can do I
already know what I can do so it's
almost kind of the prep is there the
rest of it's in that meeting you're
finding out are they the right partner
for me ethically are the right partner
for me from advice perspective they fit
that's kind of what I'm looking for and
that's what I'm shaping but prep Wise
It's just running around analytics look
at who goes who goes where
if you've got a Sean
and try and look at a squad formations
like have a look at all their product
organization
chat gbt is fantastic now you just stick
the bit of information in there tell me
about this coming so make sure you know
who the company is the prospect but also
try and understand what the vision is
and you often get up in the meeting
anyway okay so so just quickly
so non-negotiable then would be I go
into client meeting and I would be able
to articulate or understand that so it
looks like you've typically hired people
from these types of companies
why is that or like you've picked up on
that
um and then and then the other thing
that you um said there was also like in
preparation is there anything that you
can share within the market or just any
sort of Industry insights that could be
also really helpful as well so yeah yeah
like I said where they typically find
people from where does it look like
they're like tired people from
make sure you go into those prep uh yeah
prepared on that and then also what yeah
what Insight can I or value can I give
this business that could also showcase
my expertise yeah million percent so the
the first point is super simple as a
recruiter if you go find a profile from
that type of company there's a chance
you might do a deal with them because
they like that type of profile fit for
their organization so simple recruitment
is that it's how I did my first
permanent placement I asked the vprot
where do you want this person to come
from I literally went and found someone
from that company sent them over and we
did a deal in 19 days from start to then
um this side of things here is more
and and I think it can be hard for a
junior recruiter because they just need
to call somebody who's a CPO and ask
them for some time
this bit here is the high level
consulted part where and this is how you
stand out as a recruiter whereas
I understand how now we've shown in my
experience how to form a product
function what goes into a product
function product operations is something
which again is relatively new but it's
the glue which holds Now product teams
together
so my job is to go and yeah be the
solution driver for building your talent
base but also be that partner where I'm
thinking about doing this and this
what's worked best for you that's what
works really great for other companies
as well like how when you built this
team here what did they do and that's
kind of the bit which yeah that's the
Insight yeah and that's the bit which
you that kind of comes with experience
and asking the right questions so if you
don't know as a recruiter call somebody
who does um can you even be someone in
your office that's got more experience
than you one one million percent I
remember going to the meeting with a
chief data scientist I knew enough about
data science and I call the data
scientists up and I said okay
I'm just please forgive me I've not got
a job for you but I might have after
tomorrow
and just please forgive me because I
just need some help
I've got this meeting tomorrow but I
don't know what to talk about what would
you suggest and they just said ask them
about the data landscape
so the first question I asked was just
talk before your data landscape looks
like they came alive the rest of the
meeting was really easy so sometimes
even if you don't know ask somebody who
does but that's the bit there which you
almost can't be taught it that comes
with a bit of experience and asking the
right people the right questions yeah
hey everyone a real quick one from me
this podcast would not be possible
without our amazing podcast partners
vincere and saucebreaker because you
listen to this podcast you were able to
get your hands on exclusive savings on
both of these award-winning products if
you're all a growing recruitment
business you have to check out vincere
who are an all-in-one operating system
for your growing recruitment business
with Source breaker if you want to make
sure that all of your recruiters have
the best tools on the market to stand
out and beat their competition then you
have to check out Source breaker use the
link in the show notes in the comments
below and you'll be able to get yourself
exclusive savings on these amazing
products
so let's talk about this entrepreneurial
Journey then I know we went on a few
different times yeah but I enjoyed that
so why why don't we why don't we dive
into why don't we just dive straight
into like my product path because I know
that's I feel like that's yeah what
you're really excited about obviously
you started your recruitment
entrepreneurial Journey with Idol Talent
right yeah
so why don't we just dive straight into
my product path so firstly like how
how would you describe my product path
firstly like let's just let's just start
there and then I'm going to hit you with
some questions yeah it's a always a good
question when people ask me this we I
think from from a Visionary perspective
and I obviously started this when you
started this this podcast you suggested
that everyone wants to change
recruitment everyone's talking about but
no one's actually doing it
we've been doing it behind the scenes
but not talking about it
so just providing a good service
and the partnership approach is a
minimum requirement of a successful
recruiter now that's not change
that really isn't change what we're
doing at my product and how I describe
us is we're
wrapping technology around people
to create change in a sector
which is a fantastic sector it's a
sector that I'm passionate about and
that I love and it's a sector which can
make or break companies
so we're a SAS driven organization
that every money that we make every bit
every every fee that we make we put back
into the technology
we put back into the people so we're at
a tech for good SAS organization who is
streamlining recruitment services and to
build fantastic products and Technology
teams
I think that's probably the easiest way
to describe us without getting too deep
I think we're going to go yeah shortly
but that's fine it's probably the best
way to describe it so that that's the
vision but let's let's keep it real uh
right so but like so far that's the
vision but most of the revenue so far
has come from recruitment yeah Windows
yeah that's I mean we're building the
technology by the use of that and
here's the interesting thing so
self-serve is from a consumer Behavior
standpoint self-service is ever growing
every year I think I read the start that
86 of behavior in supermarkets for
example self-service nowadays everyone
uses kiosks
not sure last time you went to the
supermarket but I assume you may have
used a kiosk it depends how big the shop
is yeah so but but that's part of it and
when you look at covid
the QR codes everyone orders via QR
codes now or they were a lot of stuff we
do and a lot of the people that are
going to be hiring around you over the
next decade
it's going to be self-service
however self-service isn't doing the
answer hence why when you go to a
restaurant you've got the self-serve
aspects but you've got the people there
to help deliver it so it's kind of
you've got to combine those two aspects
to make that change and make it work
yeah so what what I just wanted to get
your thoughts on because I thought this
was interesting
why why have you sort of really lent
into like saving money fixed fee because
a lot on your website you've got two
clear pricing structures
standard cost six grand
following process recruitment interview
by product recruitment expert culture
assessment self-assessment CV submission
I think that's up to a certain salary
what salary is that up to
up to a hundred thousand then anything
left to that it's a percentage Yeah and
then executive and then executive you've
got 10K following process or criminal
interview coach of assessment psych
assessment role specific assessment
you're interviewed by CPO background
checks oh sorry that one's 100 Dearborn
seven two yeah yeah 100 then after 100
that's a percentage and we've actually
got one for now for below 70. disruption
okay to be frank it's disruption
um
when you use technology correctly
you always have a great a great talent
pool of people of product people
which means that we actually do more
deals off the back of this pricing model
so I'm going to break down one customer
that we have they're my longest standing
customer and we've been utilizing this
process with them
we saved them 84 000 pounds last year on
recruitment
will reduce the time to hire on their
rolls by 11 days
and with increased retention
and we've actually made more money over
the last year
than we did for the previous year
and we've reduced the consultant's time
in doing the roles
and the reason that why we're able to do
that is because we're plugged into the
hiring roadmap
so we can almost pipeline talent in
advance for in yeah in advance for the
partners so the reason why we've done
that is to disrupt the sector
that's kind of one example of a customer
that we've worked with a long time we've
just been competing with a digital
agency who we all know in the
marketplace
and to other companies for a new fintech
company
one of the largest pre-seage rounds in
fintech history in the UK
they're working with us exclusively now
they're working boys first
and they got rid of two agencies
and when you look at our competitors
we are now starting to win the business
from them
one because of the cost right we're in a
recession right now and if any recruiter
thinks that can still charge 20 to 30
fees in a recession and think they're
going to do as much bids that will have
over the last two or three years
they're in a Dreamland because people
are not going to spend that they're
looking at ways to cut costs that's why
unfortunately the talent acquisition
teams in most companies have been cut
first it sucks it really sucks however
the pricing model that we've generated
is the it's the longer term Vision that
nobody sees yet
this is two three four five years down
the line because our price Model won't
change we'll create different SAS models
but it won't change
so we're increasing quality whilst
driving down costs and that's disruption
but surely like this this is what I
wanted to ask you about because if
you're getting
if you're being chosen over price
is that where you want to start the
relationship I'm using that I'm using
Ash's business because they're cheaper
like is that is that yeah why would you
want to start there it's it's not about
being cheaper it's about having more
late feature layers in
okay so how many recruitment companies
have achieved product officer someone
who's got 20 years experience doing the
job
yeah not as many no I don't know I'm not
sure but you either know anyone who's
got a CPO
in as an agency in their business so so
number one we've we've got
a chief product officer
on the market and they're on the market
now but it'd be two different salaries
I'll get that you've got the industry
expertise yeah and then we've got the
understanding of what each individual
role is interview processes for each
individual role rather than just doing
okay topics what you're looking for
match the skill match match the job up
ask a bit around the skills but not
really understanding it we've got that
deep level there cultural assessment
that we've created I mean I don't know
when it comes to do a cultural
assessment
skills assessment so
the reason why the price is more
like competitive is because we've got
more Talent than most of the other
companies and we're able to utilize that
Talent better you know yourself
recruitment
how many people come out to you asking
you to look for a job and you can't help
everyone you really can't
our model kind of helps it helps us to
do that
because it doesn't cost nominal leg and
all we're doing really is redistributing
fantastic product Talent into the
marketplace
so whilst we're in a recession right now
when people talk about partnership and
when people talk about championing
change how many of those companies have
gone to their talent to their Partners
right now and said yeah you know what
it's been fantastic last two years
thanks for all the business
you're struggling right now
we'll happily drop a fees by a couple of
percent to actually help you for it
through that period
most recruiters won't do that and the
company allows that because
they don't actually care about the
partnership they care about the money
whereas we're a partnership driven
business every penny that someone spends
of us is put back into building our
technology out to Champion the change
for the future we're giving the people
back the power to choose how they want
to be represented on the marketplace to
level bias
to
literally have the option of who and
what they are when they want to be how
they want to be represented in the
marketplace and that's part of what
we're building here at my product Pastor
everyone who joins us and partners with
us that's the change which they're
they're championing
so yes it is more cost effective but
we're not the cheapest
we're just more cost efficient and cost
effective and it annoys people
and I I'll be honest it's kind of more
satisfactory because it annoys people to
me than anything else so I don't like
the words cheap
but when you look at technology and this
is what recruiters don't understand
right now is technology is going to
Simply impact the business over the next
10 years in which we're in
look at chat gbt look at what he's just
done look at how he's ruffled the
Google's feathers really really quickly
we are naive to think that technology
will not positively impact our sector it
won't solve it AI is not going to solve
everything by the way it isn't it really
isn't however
we've priced ourselves for five years
time
and we're taking a short-term hit for
the long-term vision
and that's how disruption Innovations
created
what does that short time here actually
look like it just means we make less
money on fees
it's quite simple I mean some companies
are well competitive there I mean one of
them sent an email to my consultant
saying our average fee is 18 000 pounds
it's ridiculous it doesn't need to be
that high
and most people will hate me saying this
by the way in recruitment it doesn't
need to be that high it's fantastic for
them
but we're now in a recession
they're going to lose business and we're
going to when we are winning more
business because about because we are
priced more competitively
just I just look I've been on a bit of
vagina this with this myself and my own
business and yeah I understand what
you're saying
but I feel like
you're also talking about the other
great things that you you that you built
and that you do in your service so why
why would that why would you not charge
a premium for that
do you know what I mean because it
doesn't create change
when so here's the thing when we went
through the ideation phase to create my
product path I did that during the
pandemic and we built the use case
around what the users wanted
users being who the product people
what the hiring managers are the higher
managers and the candidates okay so in
order to be the voice of the customer
which is what the Java product person is
we've got to be the voice of the
customer from from a change perspective
so I had the idea for my private path
and I like to use the traffic center as
I always use the traffic center because
I think it's a fantastic place you go
there it's all in one experience so
that's kind of what I wanted to create
and that's why we also launched the
mentoring platform as well as the
Aftercare piece but if you look at it
from from now the ideation phase I went
to over a dozen cpos
this is my idea what do you think and
Sean was a person who
most understood and was most aligned to
my vision it's the reason why we
partnered together
and from here
we speak to candidates every single day
and we'd take a pool of the candidates
to ask them okay what do you actually
want from a recruitment service
um and then we built a model around what
they wanted
so when you look at some of the
fundamental challenges is skills fit and
culture fit is is some of the hardest
bits to get correct in recruitment
that's from the from what they said
cost is number three
cost from hiring managers correct so the
cost of recruitment people suggest is
too high okay and that's from the
feedback over the last what two years
now
it's in the top three of everything than
which we do and that's from polls on
LinkedIn that's from actual feedback and
when Russ mom was speaking to customers
and everything people think recruitment
is too expensive
it is too expensive
but we're sales people so we want to try
and keep it high we want to try and push
as much what we can but is that
ethically correcting is that actual
creating positive change
not in my opinion
so what so when he was having those
conversations was there anything you
were surprised by when you're saying
what do you want from a recruitment
service
and and keep in mind the history at this
stage I I was a generalist agency
recruiter I'd started my business I was
doing traditional percentage models so
the cost for me because it's not just
the cost of the of the um actual fee
it's the wasted time of the higher
managers interviewing and when you
actually factor in and then obviously
from when people leave from a rebate
perspective
the cost of a bad high is pretty
significant and people don't add in the
fact that
higher manager's time to actually
interview cost companies a lot of money
and they've got to do this multiple
times knock at the end result
you lose thousands
thousands and thousand pounds it takes
for high manager to actually interview
so
I think the the cost was surprising to
me being that I was a percentage
recruiter building lots of money and
making good money
one actually broke it down and put
myself in their shoes
I got it and I understood it so I I do
appreciate what you're saying I I do get
it and we are adding more features in
but why didn't the future scene is
because it's what the users want no I
get that and how many recruiters
and you speak to a lot of them I've
started the business and actually asked
people what they want
we do what's right for us
because it's to make money and it's to
start a business and it's because you
can make more money doing that but how
I've actually gone to it actually okay
what do you actually want from a service
how do you want to be presented
that's a great exercise you'll know
better than me but I don't know many who
actually go and do that no look I'm I'm
a big believer of that one of the one of
the values in my company is customer
obsessed and the way that I've gone
about building
the the business that I'm building is
with actual feedback from paying
customers and their feedback what do
they want more of what they think isn't
so great like I totally get that I think
yeah I'm just challenging you a bit on
it because like I just I just think
yeah I think you've obviously explained
you've explained the the your approach
and I completely understand your your
creating the service that people want
rather than just thinking what's best
for us I totally get that I just think I
just found it interesting that it looked
like you really LED with price
when you're creating something that more
people actually want
and I think if you recruitment doesn't
have a good reputation and if you start
relationships with like I said you may
not want to be like the word cheaper but
if the internal conversations are we're
going to use my product path they're a
lot cheaper than the others yeah which
happens like is is that is that not just
a quick race to the bottom do you know
what I mean and like is that where we
want is that how we're gonna level up
the perception of our industry that
we'll just use the cheapest you know
because
but I think I understand I understand
the thought process here is like because
typically you'll hear people that charge
and work 10
I just spray and pray service yeah
all that right
but it sounds like you're charging less
but you're also building your products
and a service that people actually want
so I'm assuming it's just being it's
just boiled down to you're doing yeah
you are the reducing the price but
you've reduced it to a price that you
think is more fair that you can actually
um build a business on whilst also
building a service around it that people
actually want yeah it's what the users
want so why am I building what I want
I'm not a product manager why did you
end up on six grand then there must be
is there some science behind that or
like there's six grand and ten Grand it
was the feedback from the customers
feedback and also again I go back to
this word disruption so
I think first and foremost the customers
is at the heart of our journey and the
customer isn't just a client it's the
candidate everybody who interacts with
us they're at the harbor journey and we
are building what is right for them
are we going to make less money than
other companies short term yes
oh we're going to make more money long
term yes
because it's fundamental fact of
long-term strategy
and there's so many different ideas look
at LeBron James investing into Liverpool
long-term strategies you're gonna make
lots of money you got off the 15 million
for McDonald's to go and do that he
actually invested someone into a pizza
chain he's now making 40 million a year
or it's worth 40 million it's longer
term strategy
and money isn't the Forefront of my mind
acquiring customers and providing good
service obviously is at the Forefront of
my mind because the more customers we
acquire the more disruption we make
so the the pricing model we've got four
six 10K that's I mean if we're competing
we charge a percentage I've got to make
that clear because I'm generally we will
turn it down because we're not going to
do it
but if we're competing against other
companies we will charge a percentage
exec search is a percentage that's high
level it's it's it's different
recruitment than the generalist not the
one what's the typical percentage if
we're competing is 20 okay
so you only charge that that pricing
model when you're not competing one
million percent because when it's
exclusive or so I mean my time's worth
something still like I'm not I'm not
going to be working competing against
people for not like for minimal like
price it doesn't work like that
but the the price is based upon what the
users want so and I'll always come back
to what the users want
because
that's how the future of recruitment it
is going to move that way people don't
like it and we get we've been criticized
by some rival companies Now call them
rival companies because they're bigger
than those
and we're that startup who they're
probably looking at thinking well
actually
they're taking a few of our clients away
they're only small clients will be fine
we've got two of the largest companies
in the world working on our SAS products
right now
criticize what because you're charging
um less fees yeah because we're taking
their business away from them
which and we're also providing better
service and we're providing additional
features and when you look at the first
people that we've ever placed in my
product affecting months ago they're
still at the same companies one's been
promoted
like it it just comes down to doing the
job correct if you do your job correctly
as a recruiter you don't worry about a
frame or three-way period you don't
worry about the you don't really worry
about anything because you've done your
job correctly so
we are more cost effective but people
don't see the vision yet people don't
understand that the technology is going
to drive costs down and if people think
it's not then they're living in the
Dreamland because technology will
disrupt our sector
um
it will it's not going to solve
everything I said I always say surviving
start it's not going to solve everything
you can't solve everything with
technology
but why can't it improve it because it's
not really improved to sector yet we're
still a million years away from like
being anywhere near where we need to be
we're still probably stuck in the 90s
and we're waiting for that change to
happen so we're part of that change and
it is going to irritate a lot of the big
agencies because we're going to take
business away from them
and more for it so
the analogy that I used before with our
biggest client where we actually made
more placements then did more money and
actually reduce the the consultant's
time of delivery
that's the example we'll use because it
might seem like we're more cost
effective but we're more profitable at
the same time
you're passionate about like you said
doing things for for the positive change
so I'm glad we spoke about that and
that's that's what I was just really
curious to get your thoughts on yeah and
your perspective on so like yeah look I
think for me it's just like fair play I
think I just wanted to
understand why yeah that pricing piece
and and you you've shared why why that
is because yeah I definitely don't think
just being cheaper is the is the way
that we're going to change the
protection of our industry and I know
that isn't obviously what you're doing
no and as you've said
we offer this pricing when we're working
in Partnership when we're working
exclusive or yeah we've got a
partnership and when we are competing
then that's when um it's back to the
traditional methods so sorry I've just
done that and when you look at what I've
seen one agency who weird classes are
competitor they've just done an embedded
an embedded Talent model which is
cheaper than our fees yet we're
an embedded Talent partner to a degree
because it's partnership approach yet we
charge our fees so when people look at
being more cost effective is it I mean
it is for transactional recruitment but
from a partnership perspective it's
still more cost effective overall when
you've got now companies doing their
embedded Talent partner which they
wouldn't have done 10 years ago because
they wouldn't have they're now putting
it in as a service because they
understand
actually yes disruption actually yeah
the companies have done this they've
actually removed some business away from
us and that's what's happened so what
we're doing is building a model which
for the next five ten years will do the
same thing
so let's just end on then because this
is the what you're building your
business around
what does a good quality modern
recruitment business look like in five
years
from your perspective the technology
wrapped around the people that's
Innovation what does that what does that
mean was it like
technology wrapped around people
you'll find out in six months when we
launch the software um at a high level
like what what some of the things what
what are some of the things that
technology can enable the people part
like what what talk to us about some of
the things I think it's making
um efficiency in recruitment because you
and I both know when you do this job you
get bogged down in admin you get bogged
down in loads of media sort of I guess
minor tasks which you shouldn't be doing
so number one it's making things more
efficient is is is critical to being a
successful recruiter on the on a bit
more of a global scale because when you
look at
which you use
um or whatever it is it's just mental
how much how much is used
communication with candidates like
companies are really poor how they
communicate with candidates really poor
so having a system in place where things
are more visible to the candidate makes
makes a lot more sense to me
and it's kind of like candidates
nowadays want a choice
and they want to feel like they're in
control of the process and we need to
give them that so if we just think
sending a CV doing a deal specking the
CV over that's going to be the long-term
answer to recruitment it's not going to
be that so in five years time
fees
I think you could have two models you're
gonna have the models which are a bit
more partnership focused where they're
looking after the companies correctly
and there's always going to be the place
for the agency recruiter as it is now
doing the fees in which they are now
because some sectors don't require what
we're doing by the way
so like the construction sector for
example
something really needed for us it's
different type of work
like it's not the same same as what
we're doing but for me it's always
technology wrapped around the people and
that's how the disruption is going to
change and that's how things are going
to change in the sector service is just
one aspect of change it's not really
changed it's just doing your job
correctly
okay
see no I think I'm I'm so interested to
see how things play out that's what I
want to do it now because I want to come
back in 18 months and I want to have
this conversation again and it's almost
like a time capsule to see whether
I know I'm correct for what people want
is how this is executed will be the the
success or or fairly of the business
look the the thing that I take away
which I I massively respect is
I think yeah I think if you want
long-term success
as a recruitment business getting closer
to what it is that your clients and
candidates actually one from you from a
service is the right approach I couldn't
agree more rather than just focusing on
what is going to be best suited to us
like I I totally get that and I'll buy
into that I just think for long-term
sustainable success if you are very
close to what your customers want and
you build your services around that then
yeah like it makes complete sense so
that that's why um yeah super interested
to see how it plays out and how
recruitment companies deliver that how
they approach that you're obviously
making
um your bets on how you're approaching
that which I really respect and um yeah
look I think I wanted to challenge you
on a few things but it's only coming
from a place of just curious curiosity
you know and I respect the um the
journey that you're going on and I'm
just really interested to see how it all
plays out
yeah one million percent and I love
being challenged on it by the way so so
if anyone wants to challenge me after
this podcast please feel free to to do
that um we haven't actually been
challenged by a client to say that
should we want to pay you more
so I might will pay us what you want
then
um so yeah no I'm I I I know the future
of what our industry like the
recruitment sector I love it and it's
amazing the future of the industry is
changing
and chat gbt if people haven't noticed
that and I'll always use this as an
example
it's going to take that one moment like
that for people to sit up and be ah okay
I need to change because most
recruitment business owners right now
are just thinking about them now they're
not thinking about two three four five
years I'm five years in advance I'm not
thinking about the now
um
and that's going to be the success in
Fairly of a lot of companies over the
next five years is okay how Visionary
are they if they think the status code
of recruitment right now
is going to work in five years time when
the Gen Z start managing and hiring
people
and they don't understand who the the
user percentage of the people that were
working with
they're going to fail and they're not
going to do this correctly and that's
what we understand is the personas are
people hiring now is different
thank you for having me thank you so
much for listening to the episode I hope
you enjoyed it and got value from the
conversation if you did enjoy it please
don't forget to like share and subscribe
and we'll see you in the next episode
all right